hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem klitzekleinen info video ich habe
ja schon mal so eine kleine info gemacht
und zwar haben wir dort einen song
aufgenommen
das haben wir nun wieder gemacht also
wir sind jonathan teresa und ich wir
haben uns alle zusammen getroffen und
haben einen song aufgenommen und das
seien werte zum zweiten mal gemacht und
zwar ist es diesmal der song use
somebody von kings of leon oder
irgendwie so war das glaube ich glaube
das war der song oder beziehungsweise
der name der band und das jetzt die
datei in der premiere also wie wir das
halt geschnitten haben
und beim ersten song was er so dass ich
auch die heinzes dienst vorbereitet habe
nur ich wir sind mir die abhanden
gekommen deswegen hatte ich nie
hochladen
beim zweiten song werde ich nur noch
behind the scenes machen also wie ich
das hier alles geschnippelt empire fehlt
mir grad ida teil weiß nicht warum sie
die datei fehlt mir jedenfalls haben wir
das video nun fertig gemacht ich kann
euch jemals so ein bisschen
durchscrollen also ihr seht schon hier
wo man da dass wir das alles so gemacht
haben dass das immer so hier so
durchgeht wäre das so sieht also dass
das wirklich so in sondern sondern so
reihe geschaltet ist sage ich mal sehr
schöner schnappschuss muss ich sagen
jedenfalls wollte ich nur ganz kurz
dieses video sage ich mir hier ein
bisschen promoten also dass ihr wisst
dass wir so etwas noch mal gemacht haben
abonniert den kanal und das video steht
auch in der beschreibung also klickt
einfach drauf liegt das vielleicht das
kosten das kostet gar nicht viel zeit
solche schon sprachfehler
es ist wirklich einfach noch ein klick
das könnt ihr zwei sekunden machen
einfach nur leid man dann ist das schon
ganz cool weil wir wollen den kanal
wirklich noch so ein bisschen ich doch
mal ausbauen können da mehr videos
machen und so weiter und so fort und na
ja es wäre auf jeden fall richtig geil
wenn wir heute noch irgendwie 1000 like
schaffen können und am morgen das wäre
schon geil
und übrigens werde ich bald
beziehungsweise ich ja ich werde bald
wieder diese mit show in minecraft
machen
und ja das wollte ich euch noch mal ganz
groß ankündigen also geht bitte auf das
video like das vielleicht zeigt jetzt
euren freunden dass wir nicht richtig
nett von euch und dann würde ich sagen
sehen wir uns dann dort